We present Haptic Revolver, a
reconfigurable VR controller that
enables touch, sheer, texture, and shape
rendering on interactive surfaces.
Existing VR controllers only support
vibrotactile stimulation which is
limited in its ability to render
different textures and shapes.
What if, as you explored a virtual scene,
you could feel the surfaces you touched?
Our device haptically renders the scene by making
contact with your finger when you touch
the surface and positioning arbitrary
haptic elements in virtual space
allowing you to feel what's beneath your
finger.
The haptic revolver consists of a wheel
that contains various haptic elements.
A servo motor moves this wheel up and
down as you contact a virtual surface.
A DC motor spins the wheel to render shear forces
and position haptic elements under the fingertip.
The thumb button on the side of the controller
enables input.
Because our device is tracked we can spatially
register haptic elements with the environment.
The motor spins the haptic wheel to ensure
alignment between the features on the wheel
and the virtual scene. Through a
perceptual user evaluation we found that
we can adjust the wheel speed and
direction to manipulate the size of
virtual objects and even simulate motion
in multiple dimensions.
The haptic wheels are interchangeable and can
contain different haptic elements such as shapes,
textures, or active electronic components.
Wheels can also be custom-designed
for different applications.
For example, here we show a card table
using a wheel with various textures and edges.
When the user moves from one
surface to another our rendering engine
positions the wheel so that the
appropriate texture lies beneath the
finger and that the edge is felt in the
correct spot.
In this scene we show how shapes on the wheel
can add to the realism of a virtual keyboard.
A user can even brush along the rows of keys to
feel the grooves. By sensing the force
the finger exerts on the wheel we turn
passive elements into interactive tools.
Here we show how a simple plastic nub
can be used as the tip of a scan of
spray paint. For additional customization
electronic components such as buttons
and joysticks can be placed on the wheel.
In this scene, when the user approaches a
virtual interactive widget, the rendering
engine places an appropriate physical
widget under the fingertip. Here we show
how the user can physically interact
with virtual knobs, buttons, and switches.